Olivia Newton-John you know the actress
Olivia Newton-John she died a little
while ago and her family has been
describing paranormal experiences of
seeing her after her death
and I bring up this story because a lot
of people have these kinds of stories
they'll say oh my mother died and you
know I saw
a little something out of the glint of
my eye and I or I saw this odd little
sign I knew that was I knew that birdie
was my mother or I knew that weird image
that I saw that was my mother I felt my
mother around me and that's what they
were describing
they're saying two weeks after she
passed my phone accidentally took a
picture of my dog and they're floating
by his head with a little blue orb the
same color as this
and this is a uh
Olivia Newton John's daughter saying
this mom and I had talked years back
we'd watch these paranormal shows and
I'd say you got to show up for me and
she was like I'll show up as one of
those orb things
what do you know the phone goes off and
look there's a little orb see that's
that's Mommy
I don't mean to
drag anybody for grieving grief is very
hard thing to do
a lot of people think this is harmless
this kind of fantasy a lot of a lot of
people think it's comforting oh who
cares I don't think that's I don't think
the orb is Olivia Newton John
and a lot of people say oh it's it's
it's comforting to think that maybe you
know your mother's there
I don't think it is comforting
and as our culture has lost religion
we've we've become much more
superstitious you see this in a lot of
the most prominent ideologies these days
some of which I'm not allowed to talk
about on YouTube but you know which ones
I'm talking about a lot of bizarre
superstitions that we're engaging in
today about the nature of the Soul all
sorts of weird stuff new Agee kind of
stuff
it's not comforting though
what is comforting is systematic
theology
it is I know it doesn't sound comforting
it sounds kind of cold and clinical but
it is I know a lot of people want to say
I'm spiritual I'm not religious I don't
believe in organized religion I don't
believe in dogmas I don't believe in all
that rigidity that's all man-made that's
not I believe the spirit man you know
spirituality is not comforting religion
can be comforting
it is comforting in that it gives you
strength sometimes it's a little little
um
disruptive of what you're doing if they
tell you if your religion tells you
you're on the wrong track that can be
distressing but it'll get you back on
the right track but the reason that the
orb stuff the new AAG spirituality is
not comforting is because it raises more
questions than it answers if my mother
is a little blue orb what the hell does
that mean about the soul what does that
mean what happens after we die we all
just float around as little orbs is she
conscious is she in heaven is she in
hell is she in another dimension or I
guess she's in this Dimension or they're
just ghosts everywhere
is there God
is there Justice
what does that mean
I I have a view of what happens
which is that when you die you go to
heaven or hell
and you might need a period of
expiration you know if you're not in a
perfect state to enter into heaven but
that's it that's what happens and then
there will be a final judgment and a
resurrection of the dead and a new
Heaven and a new Earth that's that's
what I believe that's a Christian view
that's what Christians believe we say
this this kind of thing in the Creed
I believe there's a cloud of witnesses
of saints
I I believe this is expressed in the the
book of the Apocalypse where the Saints
are praying for us they've got little
little baskets which is which has
incense coming out of it which you see
reflected in the mass and that the the
incense in the buckets it's the prayers
of the saints that they're praying for
us and that God loves us and wants us to
be with him and I believe all that so
when there are little coincidences you
know if you're grieving and a little you
see a little birdie fly out the window
or you see a little orb and you say look
at that I don't think that's my mother I
don't think that's the my dearly
departed person but I do think well
there's a providential order to the
universe things make sense there is
ultimately Justice and that is
comforting but it's comforting because
the rigor of logic has been applied to
spiritual intuitions that is what
theology is theology is faith-seeking
understanding
spirituality is just BS that you try
superstitious nonsense that you try to
tell yourself to comfort yourself but
SCS Lewis points out if you look for
truth you might find comfort in the end
if you look for Comfort you'll find
neither truth nor Comfort only soft soap
and Wishful Thinking to begin and in the
end despair right now go to
helixsleep.com Knowles with everything
going on in the world right now you
could really use a good night's sleep
that is why you need to check out Helix
mattress Helix is harnessed years of
extensive mattress expertise to bring
their customers a truly elevated sleep
experience they just launched their new
Helix Elite the Helix Elite collection
includes six different mattress models
each tailored for specific sleep
positions and firmness preferences I've
had my Helix for years now I love it
night after night I sleep like a sweet
baby and I want you to do the same Helix
has a sleep quiz that matches your body
type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress because why would you
buy a mattress that was made for someone
else get out of my mattress I'm a
married man man go to helixsleep.com
Knowles take their two-minute sleep quiz
find the perfect mattress for your body
and sleep type their flexible payment
plans make it so that a great night's
sleep is never far away Helix is
offering 20 off all mattress orders and
two free pillows for our listeners hurry
over to helixsleep.com Knowles with
Helix better sleep starts right
now right now go to hillsdale.edu
Knowles are you a few years or maybe
decades out of school and wondering what
the heck did I even learn and what was
the point you might think to yourself
that you don't have the time to learn
something new well if that's you then
know that you're not alone and it's not
too late since 1844 Hillsdale College
has been providing education and Faith
freedom and character they've taken some
of the core classes they teach on campus
made them available for free online to
anyone who wants to learn that's right
for free there are 39 free courses to
choose from ranging from the U.S
Constitution the Book of Genesis to free
market economics they're easy to follow
and they're self-paced so you can start
whenever you want in fact you can start
right now it's everything you need all
in one place with no long-term
commitment let Hillsdale College be your
guide learn when and where you want
Hillsdale is absolutely terrific loved
visiting and you can bring that right
now to your home through your computer
and through your phone go to
hillsdale.edu Knowles to enroll no cost
it's easy to get started hillsdale.edu
Knowles to register hillsdale.edu
Knowles Dianne Feinstein has been
hospitalized she is the Democrat senator
she's quite aged she's a woman of a
certain age she is a 90 I think now she
had shingles earlier this year all sorts
of health problems that came from that
she's in a wheelchair she seems to have
some cognitive issues she had a fall she
was briefly hospitalized she then
returned home and people are calling on
her to step down Democrats are calling
on her to step down and oddly enough
Republicans seem even more focused on
making her step down
and I just don't see why
I don't see a single good reason
why we should call on Dianne Feinstein
to step down
I see why Democrats want her to step
down they want her to step down because
there's a Democrat Governor in
California and he can appoint some
very young robust far leftist Senator to
replace Dianne Feinstein who by the
standards of the democratic party is
relatively moderate today I get why they
want her to why do we want her to
because she is old
she we don't need all these old people
anymore
come on it's embarrassing how old she is
let's go get her out of here
that's it
that's the that is that is the degree of
strategic and tactical sophistication on
the right I'm sorry to say for a lot of
the establishment Republicans
what good is done by replacing her right
now
nothing
what bad is done you get a younger more
energetic more radical Senator who's
doing more stuff so why would we do that
well because just don't you think we
shouldn't have old people first of all
the Senate comes from the word Senex
which means old old man so I don't have
a problem with old people maybe she is a
little over the hill and should retire
but okay we've got to
cut it we conservatives need to cut it
with the rosy idealistic nonsense
about politics and start seeing power a
little more clearly I'm not saying we
behave in a way that's immoral or a way
that's unjust I would never encourage
that but we need to stop
engaging in politics as though we're
living in 1952 and nothing has changed
and we're all just dealing in good faith
and the Democrats aren't Prosecuting the
political opposition leader in the
country no they would never do such a
thing come on let's just all come
together we kind of we basically agree
in the end don't we no we don't man
they're trying to imprison the former
president the leader of the opposition
they're trying to they're spying on
Catholics they're lying about spying on
Catholics just for going to mass they're
they're calling parents domestic
terrorists they're trying to imprison
pro-life advocates for protesting
infanticide they're giving awards to the
infanticidal maniacs and they're they're
trying to throw the pro-life advocates
in prison for 10 years 11 years we're
not we're not in 1952 anymore guys
the procedural Norms are gone the only
people who are playing by the old
procedural Norms are they're
conservatives
and we're going to be playing by them
all the way to the gulags
no reason I'm endorsing Dianne Feinstein
for three more terms so glad you like
that clip and it was good but you got to
subscribe to the Michael noelshire
YouTube channel ring the bell see you
next time